[موسيقى]
دعا الامين العام للاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل نور الدين الطبوبي السلطات التونسيه
الى ما سماها التشاركيه والابتعاد عن
سياسات الاستهداف
وتتزامن دعوه الطبوب مع اتساع دائره اضراب
عن الطعام دخل فيه معتقلون السياسيون
بارزون والشخصيات تضامنت مع مطالبهم
الداعيه لاطلاق سراحهم والكف عن ملاحقه
المعارضين
اهلا بكم كنداك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات كيف نقرا مطالبات الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل السلطه في تونسيه
بتطبيق اتفاقاتها المسبقه مع الاتحاد
واعتبار الاتحاد تجميد الحكومه للحوار
بانه لا يشكل عائقا امام نضال النقابيين
والعمال وفق تعبيره وما الذي يرمي اليه
الاتحاد وما هي خياراته وكيف تستقبل
السلطات التونسيه مطالبات الاتحاد العام
للشغل وقوى سياسيه بفتح باب الحوار وعدم
انفراد الرئيس قيس سعيد للسلطه في ظل ما
تشهده البلاد من تراجع على جميع الصعد لا
سيما في الحقوق والحريات كما يقول
المعارضون
وما هي افاق الخروج من الازمه السياسيه
التي تشهدها البلاد منذ اعلان الرئيس
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه قبل نحو عامين
[موسيقى]
لم يطل اذا الصمت الامين العام للاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل نور الدين الطبوبي
فها هو يعود من بوابتي السياسه ومطالب
الاجراء ليدعوا السلطات في البلاد للكف
عما وصفه بسياسات الاستهداف والانتاج
التشاركيه لاخراج البلاد من ازماتها
المتفاقمه الطبوب قال ان تجميل الحكومه
للحوار الاجتماعي لن يعيق النقابيين
والعمال عن النضال وذاب اتحاد الشغل على
التفاعل مع ما تمر به تونس من ازمه
اجتماعيه واخرى سياسيه شهدت هاتونس في اخر
شهد في اخر فصولها دخول مزيدا من القيادات
السياسيه المعتقله في اضراب للجوع كان قد
دشنه القيادي في جبهه الخلاص المعارضه
جوهر بن مبارك ورغم دعوات محليه ودوليه
للحوار من اجل اخراج تونس من ازمتها يتمسك
الرئيس التونسي وقيس سعيد
بكونه يمضي قدما في تصحيح مسار الثوره
ومحاربه الفساد واعمال المحاسبه مشددا على
ان القانون فوق الجميع وفي المقابل يتهمه
معارضوه هو منظمات حقوقيه محليه ودوليه
بكونهم فرد بالحكم موظفا اجهزه الدوله
والقضاء من اجل ملاحقه معارضيه واسكات اي
صوت ينتقد سياساته ما جعل البلاد تشهد
انتكاسه كبيره في الحريات العامه
والسياسيه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفينا من صفاقس
لحبيب باجيلا الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن
سوسه شرق تونس قيصر الصياح المحامي
والباحث في القانون اهلا بكما وابدا معك
قيصر الصياح لنتسائل في البدايه عن ما
الذي اوصل الاتحاد التونسي للشغل الى هذه
المطالب سواء العام الداعيه للمشاركه بدل
للاستهداف او الاجتماعيه داعيه للحوار
الاجتماعي بدل رفضهم ما الاسباب
شكرا مساء الخير لاسباب بطبيعه الحال فيها
اسباب موضوعيه وفي اسباب شخصيه هناك اسباب
موضوعيه ممكن تتعلق ببعض اللقافات التي
تمت لبعض النقابيين في فتره ما منذ تقريب
خمسه وسته اشهر وراينا كيف ان الاتحاد بدا
ولوح بحرب استنزاف ضد سلطه من اجل ايقاف
هذا
الايقافات المتكرره التي طارت بعض
النقابيين
وكان الاتحاد في كل مره يهدد بان صائفه
ستنتهي وانه سيشرع ابتداء من بدايه السنه
في المطالبه بحقوقه ومن جر عنها من
مطالبات بطبيعه الحال تتعلق باتفاقيه
السابقه التي تمت مع الدوله والتي يقول
التي اتحاد انه لم يتم تنفيذها وان الدوله
معطلت وتخاذلت في ذلك ومن بين الاتفاقيه
الاخيره التي ابرمت في شهر سبتمبر من
السنه الفارطه المتعلقه بالقطاع العمومي
وبطبيعه الحال الاسباب الاخرى التي لا
تتعلق بالجانب الموضوعي واسباب شخصيه بحته
ممكن شخصيه بالمعنى الاكاديمي بالمعنى
العلمي التحليلي وهي احيلنا الى ان
الاتحاد يعني قلق جدا بخصوص ما يسميه هو
على لسانه انفراد السلطه لنفسها بنفسها
وعدم ما تشاركيتها مع الاتحاد ومكوناته
ورفض السلطه الحاكمه على راسها رئيس
الجمهوريه التونسيه الدخول في الحوار
ويعلم علم اليقين ان رئيس الجمهوريه كان
قد قام بعديد المطالبات في السنوات
الفارطه من اجل الحوار قبل حتى 25 جويلا
مع الاتحاد وكان الفشل والفشل الذريع
والصديقه
قل الرئيس هو الذي طلب بالحوار
نعم الرئيس طالب ابن حوار هناك
مواعيد حاسمه يعرفها القصد والداني قبل 25
جويليه كللت بالفشل باعتبار ان يعني
الازمه كانت محتده بين السلطه نفسها وبين
المعارضه التي كانت تحقيق
اذا كان هو الذي يدعو للحوار كما يقول
قيصر صياح شو المشكله اين المشكله ايضا
لا الحقيقه اهلا وسهلا ومرحبا بكم اولا
وبضيفكم الكريم
الحقيقه ليس صحيحا ان رئيس الجمهوريه قد
عائله الحوار مع الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل تاريخيا رئيس الجمهوريه كان واضحا
في مواقفه من الاجسام الوسيطه كما يسميها
ومن بينها الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
قبل 25 جويليه رئيس الجمهوريه في اكثر من
مره
يلتقي مع السيد نور الدين الطبوبي هناك في
احدى المرات السيد نور الدين الطبوبي اعلن
انه قريبا ينطلق حوار مع رئيس الجمهوريه
ولكن بعد ساعات قليله كذبت رئاسه
الجمهوريه هذا
الخبر ووجد الامين العام للاتحاد نفسه في
وضعيه تسلل
25 جويليه طالب الاتحاد العام التونسي
لشغل من رئيس الجمهوريه ان يحدد او ان
يصوغ خريطه طريق لمسار التصحيح كما كان
يسميه ولكن رئيس الجمهوريه اجابهم في
خطابه الشهير انه عليهم ان يبحثوا عن
الخرائط في كتب الجغرافيا فالمعلومه التي
قدمها الاستاذ قيصر الحقيقه معلومه غير
دقيقه ونحن نعرف لماذا لان رئيس الجمهوريه
بطبيعه الحال غير معني في مساره الاصلاحي
كما يتصوره هو غير معني بالاجسام الوسيطه
وهو يعتبر ان الاتحاد العالم التونسي
السيد الحبيب عن هذه الاجسام الوسيطه
نتحدث الطبوب التزم الصمت لفتره وقال الان
ان الصمت شكل من اشكال النضال في تعليق
منه طبعا على من لاحظ لزومه او التزامه
الصمت مؤخرا كيف ترى
يعني الى اي مدى مقنع هذا الكلام
لا الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل وعلى راسه
المكتب التنفيذي والامين العام السيد نور
الدين الطبوبي تماما ان بين ظفرين ان صحه
الكلمه بيلدزر
التجريف مع مسار 25 جويليه وبقياده الرئيس
قيس سعيد سيصل الى ساحه محمد علي يعني الى
مقر الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل وان رئيس
الجمهوريه غير معني ابدا باي شراكه حتى مع
الذين وضعوا انفسهم تحت سقف 25 جويليه وقد
جرب الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل على
امتداد السنتين
الفارقتين رفع ان شئنا خطاب
الاحتجاج بين ظفرين على انفراد رئيس
الجمهوريه بهذا المسار وكان الجواب
عاصفا من طرف السلطه بان وضعت الاتحاد
العام التونسي لشغل في الزاويه واعلنت
بطريقه غير مباشره انها مستعده لكي تفتح
ايضا
ولهذا السبب قال السيد نور الدين الطبوبي
ما قاله منذ اشهر بان الصمت هو ايضا طريقه
من طرق النضال بعد ان تاكد بان السيد قيس
سعيد ومسار 25 جويليه لا يؤمن بشراكه كل
المكونات التي يعتبرها قد اففت العشريه ما
لم يفهمه المساندوه 25 جويليه وعلى راسهم
الاحزاب ومنظمه الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل وباقي منظمات المجتمع المدني التي
ساندت صبيحه يوم 25 جويليه
الانقلاب على دستور 2014 واغلاق البرلمان
ما لم يفهموه ان رئيس الجمهوريه يعتبر
الجميع
منظمات
ومجتمع مدني واحزاب يعتبرها كلها شريكه في
العشريه التي يعتبرها هو عشريه خراب
ويختبرها عشريه على ما سماه نعم يعني
الكل في سله واحده يضع الجميع في سله
واحده ما هنا دعني انتقل الى قيصر الصياح
لو ربطنا بين العام والخاص او بعباره اخرى
بين النقاب والسياسي ما هي اهداف اتحاد
الشغل من ورائي مواقفه التي يمكن وصفها
ربما برساله للسلطه الحاليه في تونس
واضح ساعارج على هذا ولكن الرئيس عندما
دعا الى الحوار اكد السيد طابوق الجميع
لقاءاته والتي شاهدناها على التلفاز
مباشره من قصر قرطاج خلال سنه الفرطه وما
قبلها تقريبا رئيس الجمهوريه في كل
توجهاته وانه قريب منه الى درجه تجعله
يتحد في القرارات واتخاذ المواقف بدليل ان
السيد الطبوبي منذ اربعه عشر يعني بتاريخ
عيد الشغل واحد
قرر الادلاب بتصريح لوكاله تونس افريقيا
الانباء وقال اثمن قرارات رئيس الدوله
فيما اتخذهم القرارات تتعلق بسياده
الوطنيه وخاصه برفض صندوق قرارات صندوق
النقد الدولي وسياسه لي الذراع وما علينا
الا العمل ويجب تجاهل هؤلاء الاشقاء
وعلى راس الدوله لكن يبدو ان الموقف اختلف
هذه المره بناء على التصريحات الاخيره
للاتحاد ومطالبته للسلطات التونسيه بتطبيق
اتفاقاتها المسبقه مع الاتحاد
وفيها شقان طبعا الشق النقابي
والاجتماعي والسياسي
يعني اختلطت الامور بطبيعه الحال نحن
راينا كيف ان الامور احتدت والخلاف
والسياسي بين جميع اطرافهم ومكوناته من
بين الاطراف السياسيه التي كانت يعني
مخالفه لقيس سعيد ثم انتقلت فيما بعد
معارضه
مسانده له
والعكس بالعكس راينا كذلك الاتحاد وكيف ان
كل احد يريد ضمن يعني اطار التموقع
السياسي ولعبه السياسي او ما يسمى
بجغرافيا السياسيه الداخليه حتى موقع
وافتكاك يعني مقعد للتفاوض او الاقتراب
بين السلطه
لجعل البوصله السياسيه متوازنه ضمن
الخارطه السياسيه الجديده التي يريد
الاتحاد كما داب عليها وتعود عليها في
السنوات الفارطه لكن للاسف الشديد ما ذهب
علي الاتحاد واقبل منظمه في تونس ونحترمه
ونجله ذهب على ثلاثه اتفاقيات ضمن يعني
الاتفاقيات اتفاقيات الشراكه مع السلطه
القائمه في عهد البهجي قال السبسي وفشلت
كل التي ابرمت بقرطاج وادت الى ما نحن
عليه في 110 الف مليار ديون و16.9 مليار
عجز تجاري وانعدام الانتاج تماما بالبلاد
و700 الف موظف من اعلى من اعلى ان يسب في
العالم تقريبا في حدود السادسه والسابعه
عالميا بالمقارنه مع النمور الديموغرافي
الموجود في تونس وليس هناك ما يضاف الى ما
نحن فيه الان عدا ان السيد الطبوبي
ربما
تساؤل عن الخيارات وهنا تحول الى الحبيب
وعجيله
اي خيارات الان ما زالت امام الاتحاد
اتحاد الشغل خاصه وان الرئيس سعيد كما قلت
انت ايضا قبل قليل يرفض الحوار مع الجميع
وهناك من مؤيدي قيس سعيد ايضا
من اثار ملفات ستطال الاتحاد ومن فيه
ملفات فساد غير بعيده عن ساحه اتحاد الشغل
انظري سيدتي الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
يدرك تماما ان سمعته دعني اقول في علاقه
بالشعب التونسي على امتداد عشر سنوات هي
تقريبا نفس سمعه الطبقه السياسيه يعني
هناك فكره عامه سائده لدى الجميع ان
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل ساهم على
امتداد عشر سنوات في اعاقه الانتقال
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي وانجز العديد من
الاضرابات الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
يدرك ان صورته في اوساط الشعب التونسي
ليست بالقدر الذي يجعله قادرا الان على ان
يرفع صوته للاحتجاج والشراكه السياسيه مع
السلطه القائمه سيقولون له انت عشر سنوات
وانت تقرر وانت تفعل ما تريد وتفرض ما
تريد وتشترط ما تريد على كل الحكومات
وتريد الان ان تكون جزءا من مسار بين
ظفرين تصحيح المسار هذا م ايضا الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل يدرك ان الرعاه
الدوليين دعني اقول للتجربه الانتقاليه في
تونس وللثوره وللانتقال الديمقراطي
يحملونه هو وجزء كبير من المجتمع المدني
مسؤوليه التصعيد ومسؤوليه التعفيين
ومسؤوليه التعطيل التي مورست في علاقه
بالاحزاب والحكومات المختلفه التي تعاقبت
على حكم البلاد ولم تتعاون للمنظمه منظمه
الاتحاد لم تتعاون مع الحكومات المختلفه
لكي تجد ارضيه للاصلاح الذي كان يمكن ان
يغني البلاد عن الالتجاء الى حادثه 25
جويليه باعتمارها ايقافا كاملا للمسار
واعاده ترتيب للاولويات اذا الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل يدركه ايضا ان هذه السلطه
تتحرك ضمن هذين المعيارين بالاضافه طبعا
هذين المعيارين فقط لضيق الوقت لانه الوقت
سيداهمنا قصر صياح اذا كان يعني السلطه
الان وانت قبل قليل كنت تتحدث بالاحصائيات
والارقام عن الازمه السياسيه والازمه
الاقتصاديه والديون وغير ذلك وهناك غياب
للحوار مع اتحاد الشغل هناك ملاحقات
قضائيه لقاده ورموز المعارضه والبلد او
البلاد تغرق في ازماتها الاجتماعيه
وازمتها الاقتصاديه وغير ذلك كيف برايك
سترد السلطه على خطاب اتحاد الشغل
نعم السلطه بطبيعه الحال وكانت متناغمه في
عديد القرارات مع اتحاد الشغل وخاصه اذا
اذا ادركنا ان السلطه منذ تقريبا سنه
سنه تقريبا ابرمت سفاقيات مع اتحاد الشغل
فيما يتعلق بالقطاع العمومي والذي يشمل
700 الف موظف تونسي وسيكون له يعني الواقع
الكبير المالي على ميزانيه الدوله رغم ضعف
قدراتها وضعف قدرات مموليها ونحن نعلم
دوله هي قدرات ممولها ونعلم ان الحكومه
قامت بعديد المفاوضات مع الاتحاد السنه
هذه والسنه الفارطه وادت الى زياده في
اجور القطعه الخاص وغيره يعني الحوار مع
اتحاد الشغل لم ينقطع ثوان مع حكومه
النجله بودن او مع الحكومه الحاليه فقط ان
التجميد الذي حدث الان حدث حدث نتيجه هو
تجميل وليس انقطاع او توقف فقد تجميد حدث
نتيجه خلاف بسيطه تتعلق باحدى الفقرات
الموجوده في الاتفاق الذي كان سري للغايه
ونحن نعلم كيف تبعنا تلك الاتفاقيه في شهر
سبتمبر 2022 يعني لم يدخل احد حتى من
الصحافه وكانت خاصه بين الاتحاد وبين
الحكومه هاته الاتفاقيه تقول كذلك ويجب
على كل المتابعين ان يقراوا هذا الامر من
بتفاصيله في الباطن لا نقرا الظواهر
بظاهرها التي فاق ينص على انه يمكن زياده
بدايه شهر اكتوبر الحالي وانا استغرب كيف
ان الاتحاد من اليوم الاول الان نحن يوم
الاثنين اكتوبر انطلق مباشره في المطالبه
بهذه الزياده التي يمكن ان تكون بعد ايام
اخرى والاتحاد بطبيعه الحال وجد نفسه
مضطرا للدخول من جديد فيما يسمى
بالصيحات
النقابيه التي يريد منها شان سياسيا وهذا
امر بطبيعه الحال من حق الاتحاد ان يكون
جزءا من مكون السياسي لان هذا الامر لا
يعني اطلاقا ان الدوله او السلطه القائمه
اوقفت الحوار مع اتحاد الشغل بدليل ان
الحكومه ابرمت كل الاتفاقيات القطاع الخاص
والقطاع العام اريد ان اقول فقط في كلمه
يؤكد واستعداد الحكومه والدوله للحوار مع
اتحاد شغل بدليل ان هذا الاتفاق يشمل 180
مؤسسه عموميا
فقط عن الاتحاد
نقاش يعني يمتد الى المشهد السياسي برمته
وهنا ثاني اعود مره اخرى الى الحبيب
بوعجيله هناك طبعا ازمه الخيارات الموجوده
لدى السلطه هل هي لدى الحكم فقط ام لدى
المعارضه ايضا بكل ما تشهده المعارضه من
مشاكل من انقسامات وتشتت وغير ذلك
هو يبدو انك انت مش مهتمه بوجهه نظري برشا
لانك ما اعطتنيش الوقت الكافي ولكن
شكرا لكن اريد ان اقول ان الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل وداتا 25 جويليه 2021 لم
ينحز الى الجهه التي يجب ان ينحاز اليها
حتى لا يجد نفسه في هذه الوضعيه الان
المعزوله في علاقه بالسلطه كان عليه ان
ينحاز الى الديمقراطيه كان عليه ان ينحاز
الى عشريه الانتقال الديمقراطي التي كان
طرفا اساسيا فيها والتي حولته الى طرف
اساسي التي الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
على امتداد 23 سنه في حكم الاستبداد مع بن
علي كان طرفا وظيفيا لا قيمه له ولا اهميه
كبرى رغم ان قواعده كانت تدعوه الى ان
يكون الى جانب الديمقراطيه جاءت الفرصه
وجاءت عشريه الانتقال لم يترفق بها
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل للاسف ولم
يشترك مع القوه السياسيه واسس علاقته معها
على اساس موقف ايديولوجي للمكتب التنفيذي
الجديد الذي تولاه وهو مكتب طبعا
اقام علاقته مع الانتقال الديمقراطي على
اساس الاستقطاب الايديولوجي مع حركه
النهضه يوم 25 جويليه عوضا ان ينحاز الى
الديمقراطيه انحاز الى الانقلاب يعني اقول
بين ضفرين وبالتالي وجد نفسه اليوم معزولا
وضعيفا لا يستطيع ان يدافع عن منظريه لانه
فرط في الاساس والمرتكز الذي كان يمكن ان
يجعل منه طرفا اساسيا وهو الديمقرا
الاتحاد السيد الحبيب الان
النقاش القيصر وكان لابد ان تريني حتى
الرد نعم لكن المعارضه الان مع اتساع
دائره الاضراب يعني الا تعتبر هي ايضا
ضحيه واقعها ضحيه انقساماتها ضحيه غياب
برنامج سياسي واضح لدى المعارضه ايضا
هي اولا ضحيه التسلط هذا امر لا نقاش فيه
علينا ان نحدد السبب الرئيسي والاسباب
الثانويه هي الان على امتداد سنتين
ضحيه لتسلط حكم انفرادي لا يريد ان يتحرك
احد في هذه البلاد الا صوت السلطه الحاكمه
هذا امر اساسي ان على المعارضه كان عليها
بعد 25 جويليه ان تراجع نفسها ان تطرح على
نفسها اسئله لماذا يعني فشل الانتقال
الديمقراطي لماذا وقع انقلاب 25 جويليه
علينا ان نجدد انفسنا علينا ان نجدد
افكارنا انا معك في ذلك ولكن يا سيدتي على
امتداد سنتين كنا نواجهه سلطه منفرده
بالراي
حتى الذين قالوا لها نعم نحن معك في تصحيح
المسار ابعدتهم ولم تتحاور معهم مما يعني
في اخر التحليل ان هذه السلطه لم تترك
الان للمعارضه فرصه ان تقدم رؤاها
وتصوراتها وحتى نقدها الذاتي انت تعلمين
ان يعني المعتقلين الان السته الذين
يدخلون اليوم في اضراب جوع
كان كانوا يتشاورون من اجل صياغه تصور
الشديد للمعارضه فيه نقد ذاتي وفيه مقترح
وفيه اعتذار للشعب التونسي على الاخطاء
التي ارتكبتها الطبقه السياسيه وفيه تقديم
للبديل الذي يمكن ان تتجه اليه تونس من
سلطه حتى
نعم تفضل لكن القي عليهم القبض القي عليهم
القبض ومنعت هذه الوحده التي تتحدثين عنها
هم بداوا المعارضه بدات تتناقش لكي تصل
الى الوحده اولا لكي توقف عمليه الانقسام
التي افشلت العشريه لكي تراجع تصوراتها
لكي تبني بدائلها ولكن السلطه بطبيعه
الحال لم تمهلها فعندما تقولين كان على
المعارضه كذا وكان على المعارضه كذا انا
ايضا اقول ونحن نكتب كذلك في هذا الاتجاه
ونقول على المعارضه ان تفعل كذا ولكن
الجواب ان ما على المعارضه ان تفعله لا
يمكن ان يكون في سياق محاصرتها وملاحقتها
ووضعها في السجون انت تتذكرين الاجواء
الفكريه والنقاشات التي انطلقت عندما
انطلقت ناطرون ضد الانقلاب وعندما بعد ذلك
تشكل جبل نعم
النقاش التي كنا نستطيع ان نجعل شكرا
جزيلا
ادركنا واعتقد انني انصحتك في الجزء
الاخير من البرنامج
بهذا هذه الفسحه من الوقت شكرا جزيلا لك
الحبيبه جيلا الكاتب المحلل السياسي
التونسي كنت معنا من صفاقس وشكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من سوسه قيصر الصياح المحامي
والباحث القانوني شكرا لكما
والى هنا ينتهي وتنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج نور الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]